let's try Ricky from Charlotte and see
if Ricky from Charlotte can help us
recover
um Ricky welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
beautifully
okay cool yeah so I wanted to ask you
about this right-wing Civil War that we
see starting to unfold yeah and I'm I'm
just curious I'm not exactly sure like
what the
like what the dividing lines around this
will be I mean I guess we could say like
in the context of going into the 2024
primary it could be the Trump versus
DeSantis line but I'm I'm really curious
about like what the fracture will make
you you know like what the Civil War
will make them look like fractured after
like this whole thing is done and
whether there could be like any sort of
permanent split that could benefit the
left you got what I'm asking a hundred
percent and it's a really hard thing to
predict but it's a really astute thing
to be wondering about because up until
weeks ago really the dividing line has
been you've got your pro-trump and your
anti-trump Republicans fine when the
speaker vote came that ultimately led to
Kevin McCarthy becoming Speaker of the
House you had a further subdivision of
that where you had anti-trump but then
you had pro-trump that likes McCarthy
and pro-trump that says we need an
alternative so it was like Marjorie
Taylor green versus Lauren bobert the 24
election is going to be its own thing
because for example you're completely
right you've got the DeSantis and Trump
part of it but now you also have for
example Nikki Haley Nikki Haley worked
in the Trump Administration she was
Trump's uh ambassador to the U.N but now
she's running against Trump but the
other wrinkle to it is Trump actually
needs as many people as possible to jump
into the primary because if you look at
head on one-on-one polls between Trump
and DeSantis it's very good for DeSantis
when you include more people in the
polls
it's better for Trump because they take
away support from DeSantis so it's weird
because Nikki Haley is a former Trump
staffer who's running against Trump but
Trump actually benefits from the field
being more divided so you're asking a
really great question which is after it
all shakes out then what does it the
party look like and it depends whether
Trump wins or doesn't win if Trump loses
the primary whatever the split is
between now and and July of 2024. if
Trump loses the primary
all bets are off in the sense that there
will be a realignment of the Republican
Party altogether and they might even say
Hey you know we also don't want the
Marjorie Taylor greens get them all the
hell out of here if Trump does win the
primary then there will be a question of
whether the anti-trump Republicans have
had enough and they want to really try
to do something invoking Force Major or
something along those lines it's so
hypothetical Ricky that I don't know but
it's a fascinating question
yeah no I'm I'm really curious to see
where it goes but like my general thing
is I just hope that it causes like
permanent lasting damage I you know I
believe like what Chomsky said that
Republican party is the most dangerous
organization in human history and like
so I just root for their downfall and
it's been really interesting to see how
um some of the infighting that we've
seen you know over the last few years
sort of on the left at least like in the
Independent Media space yeah seems to be
really consuming the right because the
right you know the Republican Party in
the right teams would be like more you
know closely United with their whole
like internet culture and Independent
Media culture so I don't know if you've
seen some of these characters like a
Laura Loomer she's this really crazy
fart right like yeah Nick Fuentes
adjacent unfamiliar um yeah and she's
like going hard again she's like
essentially leading like a trump robust
movement for 2024 and they're calling
DeSantis essentially calling it a stance
it's like a lefty and all this stuff and
the interesting how about that Ricky if
I may is some of that infighting that
took place on the left it's with people
that we now all know aren't really on
the left like it's so it's so funny to
give a couple examples Jimmy Dore and
Glenn Greenwald I don't know if you're
familiar with them it's funny because at
one point it was sort of well accepted
that they're part of quote the left but
then as the infighting began it kind of
became clear that they're kind of
reactionary libertarian populists really
and and that is not exactly on the left
and now you know Jimmy Dore is doing his
own thing in Glenn Greenwald I think is
on like rumble or something like that I
don't hear anyone on the left still
considering them part of the left
anymore and it's sort of like become
very clear that a lot of these people
really weren't on the left if that makes
sense
yeah I think well yeah I know that like
Jimmy and
there are some others I don't know like
uh Michael Tracy or some of these other
people especially like around the issues
like the Ukraine borders who claim to be
like the true leftist still and I just
think that the interesting thing with
that is and this can be my conspiracy
theory I think a lot of those characters
are were being played by like some sort
of Peter Thiel
um deal you know in order for them to to
get rich and they never really believed
in interesting doing the shift that they
believed in but I just hope that like I
would love to see the the a similar
thing like that actually happened to the
right because I feel like it could be
more damaging because that's more tied
to their like mainstream culture than
you know the left independent means
because these characters on the right
that are involved in these tiffs they
really are on the right like when when
the Jimmy Dore thing happened it was
like oh this guy's not on the left but
these right Wingers really are on the
right they're it's not like oh you know
it turns out Laura Loomer is actually a
leftist like obviously that's not
exactly so it has the potential to be
much more damaging yeah okay well let's
hope it works let's hope yeah all right
my friend thank you very much
there's Ricky from Charlotte great to
hear from him let's go next to Johnny
from Toronto we will go to our friendly
neighbors to the north Johnny from
Toronto I'm inviting you to speak once
you accept and properly configure your
audio device hopefully you and I will be
able to have dialogue
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
fine all right David sir it's so great
to be here I kind of have tears in my
eyes I hope my audio is not too bad but
uh I just had a quick question yeah in
relation to your workout program okay I
remember a few a few months back you
mentioned that you weren't quite
comfortable going back to the gym I'm
back at the gym uh yes I was just kind
of interested and curious if you had a
workout program and what that looked
like and because I had a follow-up
question to this as well yeah I mean so
so just to make sure I didn't step on
you I I am back at the gym at this time
not literally now right now I'm in my
studio but I mean I'm going to the gym I
basically alternate forms of cardio
between running elliptical and rowing
machine and then rotate through
different weight lifting elements
targeted at different parts of the body
I hit the body with weight
okay got it got it yeah and I I guess my
follow-up question was I remember a few
weeks of probably a couple bucks back at
this point there was someone who uh I
think they left you a voicemail or an
email where they said that oh you're
like 150 pounds uh I don't even remember
like calling it a data or something like
that and I was wondering do you think
it's kind of a bit of a humorous
question do you think people on the
right might take you slightly more
seriously if you decided to like bulk up
and gain 20 pounds of muscle or
something like that you know I'm not
sure number one because it's not really
that obvious when looking at screens I
don't think and as a counter example I
got word through our team that Ben
Shapiro has been lifting weights and
apparently has put on some some you know
modest amount of muscle and I don't see
anyone taking him anymore seriously
okay I I understood got it
well thank you for the opportunity to
talk man I appreciate it all right
Johnny from Toronto thank you very much
uh important questions for sure that I I
I can't can't ignore those types of
questions because they are critical to
the culture War I would say plastic it's
everywhere we look and not enough is
being done about it 100 billion plastic
bags are used and thrown away every year
here's something super simple you can do
to reduce plastic and help the planet a
little bit our sponsor hold on bags is
the company making plastic free trash
bags and zip seal kitchen bags they're
just as strong and high quality as the
plastic bags you're used to hold on bags
are 100 percent plant-based and home
compostable meaning they break down in
just weeks not decades their zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
size to fit all of your needs whether
it's carrots or crayons at home I put
all of my food waste in a whole on trash
bag throw it in the compost pile and
when I throw a hold on trash bag in my
dumpster I love knowing it's not filling
our landfills and oceans with plastic
single-use Plastics harm the planet at
every Stage production disposal
decomposition join the growing movement
away from single-use plastic these
products are really great it's so easy
to make the switch go to holdon bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below